دعنا نراها بأعيننا ، أود
أن أشغل الشريط الذي كان عليه
في الطاقم ،
حسنًا ،
لا بأس فقط مساحة
[موسيقى]
أوه ، هذا رائع ، هل يمكنك تحريك رأسك
قليلاً أوه نعم
[موسيقى]
أوه نعم جاهز
[موسيقى
] حسنًا ، انظر ما إذا كنت قد التقطت هذا في فمك
[موسيقى]
أوه أحبها
واو
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
كان كل ما كنت تتوقعه وأكثر من ذلك
كنت تنتظر كما قلت ست
سنوات لتجربة هذا الذي أحببته  كل
دقيقة من ذلك ، أتمنى أن تكون
أطول قليلاً لأنني كنت في الفضاء من
قبل وليس في الفضاء مع
ما يصل إلى تلك المنطقة ويمكنني القيام بالكثير من
اللفات واللفائف وما إلى ذلك ولكن
لم يكن هناك مساحة
كافية لنا جميعًا.  للقيام بكل هذه الأشياء
، كان رائعًا ، لقد أحببته ، وبالكاد يمكنني
الانتظار للذهاب مرة أخرى ،
آمين المحطة التالية لأنك هي والي القمر